et pour gênes berg ancien ambassadeur et
essayiste c'est à l'union européenne de
pousser le cren au dialogue pour éviter
tout conflit armé il faut que l'ukraine
négocié avec ces régions ce que
l'ukraine ne veut pas faire et il c'est
à nous de pousser l'ukraine elle doit
dialoguer elle si elle cherche à
résoudre le problème par la force il y
aura une intervention russe pour
protéger un petit peu j'irai ses
concitoyens ou le monde russes c'est
dangereux et donc il faut que nous les
européens tous le cren à dialoguer et
les russes le montre le martèle tous les
jours tant qu'on n'aura pas fait ce pas
on aura avancé si on n'a pas fait des
pas avant mars avril pour désamorcer on
a un risque vraiment d'une situation
d'une véritable
guerre froide qui risque de nous
entraîner dans un cycle
qui sera qui sera négatif pour tout le
monde